hello friends this is Ashley Vance the
host of hello world and thanks for
joining me for this journey along the
Esplanade and Helsinki this is a special
VR edition of hello world so now is the
time to put on your fancy goggles all
this stuff was shot in 180 degrees with
a stereoscopic camera and we just wanted
to give you guys a peek at how we make
the show while we were shooting the full
version of hello world Finland
[Music]
[Music]
Sunday morning in Helsinki with the
hotel Kampf right in the center of the
city can I interview an author this
morning who wrote a book about the fall
of Nokia to find out what went wrong
with Nokia and maybe how Finland has
recovered a bit this is a little bit of
how we set up the interviews that you'll
see throughout the episode for the
camera buffs out there you can see my
director David Nicholson nerding out the
art of TV hosting I've discovered here
is making small talk with your subjects
holding back what you really want to ask
them until the cameras are on yeah I
mean I am working on now I just sold my
next one yeah so I don't know if writing
has officially started but I'm still I
am I'd need to be writing yeah I'm still
I got a little bored yeah yeah you can
never promote your new books too early
this was shot at a startup incubator in
Helsinki this company is called Navi
and they make the coolest green walls
I've ever seen yeah so this is a
biofilter where we kind of washed off
the soil from plants we we kind of place
it into this biological filter which is
a consists of seven seven different
ingredients
some of them stabilize the pH for the
plants some of them keep the humidity
for the plants and water and so on
some of them provide a surface space for
the microbes to thrive and so on so it's
a kind of a combination of different
things it took us like two and a half
three years to make make this mixture
this is Mya she runs golden-green which
makes a sort of meat replacement that's
really popular throughout Finland a big
theme in kind of the middle of the
episode is food and all the weird
science that's going on in Finland
around
types of protein and meat replacements
before we hit up the labs there was this
herring festival going on it's just
right in downtown Helsinki it's pretty
cool a lot of action and kind of this
mix of tourists and locals
[Music]
this is solar foods I think of it as
like the kind of breaking bad version of
making food in Finland they make food
out of thin air they grab the air they
throw it into some bacteria and cook it
as a TV host you have to give up part of
your control and just be placed where
they want you this is at the
headquarters of golden green with Maya
who you saw earlier one thing I found
with the Finns is that they were really
secretive around their technology and
wouldn't let me see it
fusion lab
but a self-driving car yeah but there's
definitely bits where they're like
please don't show this thing or anything
but I don't it just happened out three
days in a row I think I think your fins
are
[Laughter]
there's some sin robotics robots that
sort out the trash get ahead in save do
their work and I can kill me
if you get a visited dump this is the
one you want to see because you got your
garbage trucks we've got some robots in
this one super fancy AI robots pretty
cool so the dump trucks come and just
bring this whole pile of stuff kind of
gets pre sorted by some humans and some
other machines and then it ends up on
this conveyor belt where the robots
really go to town using AI to grab metal
and wood and plastic and swing it out
into the right place something sort of
mesmerizing about the trash getting
sorted into these piles and we've gone
through the whole convey about line
[Applause]
okay this was my favorite I'm here with
a future Finnish Olympian lasse atlatl
Oh whose name I've learned to say we
were going to practice the ancient
Finnish art form known as cellphone
throwing it I was doing research for
this episode it turns out that Finns are
in the really weird kind of competitions
like wife-carrying
and and cell phone throwing they did
this for years and our man lasse here
was an actual cell phone growing
champion I mean this looks pretty
ridiculous but I think it sort of had a
purpose which was a lot of our episode
focused on the fall of Nokia and I
thought it would be a good idea to throw
some Nokia phones to help get into
things and see if they held up they're
sort of famous for being pretty sturdy
it turns out they held up pretty well
except I don't think anything could
survive this guy throwing it this is me
doing my hosti thing in a tram the trams
are pretty awesome part of Helsinki my
director David made me record this in
the tram a little embarrassing because
the I was bagging on Finland a bit and
they all speak English
these are the eyelash spools it's right
at the the edge of like downtown
Helsinki they're really cool you can go
in this which is like the regular
temperature pool or you can go freeze
your everything off in the Baltic Sea
pool if you watch the full episode you
can see me humiliate myself do that
here's David torturing me again telling
me how to make bubbles the right way
[Music]
you even got Diana here as a coach
bubble-making partner hi suppose
that's it please watch the full version
of hello world Finland and leave us any
tips for things you'd like us to do in
VR or anything we can do to kind of you
know make the show better for you guys
[Music]